Let's go next to our color from the seven
six zero area code.
Who's calling today from seven six zero.
I think that's my advantage.
Yes it is.
Hi, my name.
I actually don't really have a phone right
now.
All right.
I can hear.
I can barely hear you.
It sounds like you're sort of underwater or
are you using a Bluetooth headset right now?
Oh, I shouldn't be.
Let me try something.
It'll just take me two seconds.
All right.
Yeah.
Can you hear me better now, David?
Yes, I can.
Okay.
Hi.
Um, my name is Marshall.
I'm from Orlando, Florida.
Did you get that?
Yes, I did.
Okay.
Uh, so I'm doing a bit of an academic project.
I consider myself an objectivist and so I'm
kind of trying to get the best critiques of
objectivism that are out there.
I know obviously you've probably somebody
who doesn't agree with objectivism, you know,
the Radian variety.
Um, I've been trying to scour the internet
looking for like the best, like, you know,
systematic academic base take downs of her
philosophy.
Have you seen anything or like your, could
you point me to the best actual critique instead
of like not ad hominem attack on her character
or half-baked attempts that you don't have?
I don't, I've not taken a deep dive into critiques
of objectivism, so I mean I, I would be shy
if you were to Google and including, if you
go to Google scholar and search for critiques
of objectivism, I'd be shocked if it was ad
hominems about iron Rand
[inaudible]
right, right.
So I see.
So it's mainly like the internet article they
should avoid like you know, the like journal
journals and major news websites and stuff
like that.
Like actually look for academic critique.
Well if you're, you, you said you were looking
for an academic critique, so if that's the
case I would look on Google scholar
[inaudible]
Google scholar.
Okay.
Well thank you David.
All right.
Thank you for the call Marshall.
I appreciate it.